[Música]
gracias gracias
qué gusto saludarlos a todos a todas
yo soy jorge lozano h y más de uno más
de una vez estará viendo ahorita a
través de este vídeo ya estar diciendo
qué suerte tiene ese muchacho
en té de c's con su conferencia y
viéndose como un muñeco
válgame dios gracias muchas gracias el
conferencia se llama la suerte no es
suficiente y me gustaría empezar
contándoles una historia una historia de
una mujer que se llama cruyff
sting krivets tiene a una mujer que
amaneció un día y se fue a su trabajo
como muchos de los que estamos aquí como
muchos que nos están viendo a través de
este vídeo llegó a ese lugar perfecto en
el que ella trabajaba una empresa
financiera primermundista se sentó en su
lugar de trabajo en uno de los días más
bonitos que había visto y de repente
recibió una llamada la llamada de ese
compañero o compañera argüende era que
tenemos a veces en la oficina te ha
tocado de ese compañero que te habla y
compañera estamos por un cigarrito un
cigarrito ándale porque es un cigarrito
y aquella decía no compañero muy bien
ocupada muy bien ocupada un cigarrito
compañera pues vamos hoy a aquella se
sube al elevador piso 67
el que trabajaba y mientras bajaba iba
platicando charlando se abren las
puertas del elevador y lo que ve en el
lobby de su edificio era una escena de
película
todo mundo petrificado como si el tiempo
se hubiera detenido la mujer que pasa
aquí sale caminando del edificio y de
repente ve como la gente estaba afuera
se abran las puertas automáticas y todo
mundo con la vista al cielo y esta mujer
que les pasa y de repente decide sumarse
para ver qué había y ve que hay
periódico cayendo ve que hay fragmentos
de cosas cayendo del edificio y la mujer
en en sorpresa voltea y el edificio que
estaba enfrente estaba en llamas
prendido en fuego eran nueve de la
mañana con tres minutos de repente a la
mujer voltea al cielo y un avión le pega
exactamente arriba de donde estaban sus
oficinas al edificio del que acababa de
salir
ella estaba ahí un 11 de septiembre del
año 2001 una decisión minúscula un
cigarrito un momento es increíble por
eso me dedico yo a dar conferencias y mi
conferencia se llama la suerte no es
suficiente porque una decisión te cambia
todo o ya no sé si alguien ha jugado
golf alguien que esté viendo este vídeo
ha jugado golf alguna vez en la vida que
se ha puesto así es increíble como cómo
funciona el golf mueves la cabeza del
bastón de golf un centímetro y la bola
se va a kilómetros de distancia la
suerte es curiosa las decisiones son
curiosas seguramente tú conoces gente
que parece que nació con ángel que nació
con estrella afortunada en todo pero
también conoces gente más salada que un
bacalao te ha tocado que si va caminando
por una avenida de 40 metros ya hay un
pozo de 5 centímetros
caer en el mendigo pozo me ha tocado que
acaba de conocer a una persona se
enamora de esa persona esa persona lo
invita o la invita a signar a casa de
sus papás llega por primera vez a casa
de los suegros le dan ganas de ir al
baño y tapa el baño
y dices no puede ser y no hay fuerza
humana que pueda destapar ese baño no
puede bajar dios a abrir los mares
dentro de ese retrete para que se
destape y estás sudando la gota gorda
que que por qué yo porque a mí hay gente
que se pregunta le pasan cosas dices es
que porque parece que dios hubiera
acumulado todo el mugrero del mundo para
depositarlo en graciela todo el mujer o
toda la mala suerte toda la sala dencia
para depositarla en mariana en juan en
quique porque a mí fíjate hay muchas
definiciones de suerte muchas
definiciones los mayas los aztecas
tenían su definición de suerte ellos
creían que la suerte llegaba a base de
sacrificios humanos sacrificaban un
corazón le ofrecían al sol y pues que se
les vaya bien no y bueno no estaban tan
perdidos la suerte de alguna manera si
funciona con algo de sacrificio por
ejemplo la cultura hinduista tenía la
creencia del karma tiene la creencia del
dharma que si obras bien te va bien que
el que obra mal
se le pudre el tamal y bueno es su
creencia pero yo creo que la suerte se
basa en un componente crucial y me
encanta esta definición que les presento
aquí la suerte es la manera en la que
catalogamos el resultado de nuestras
decisiones
oye que algunos nacieron con estrella
que algunos nacieron mira con cuchara de
plata con toda la prosperidad pues bueno
resultado de las decisiones de sus
padres de los padres de sus padres del
gobierno en aquel entonces de la empresa
en la que trabajaba hay gente a la que
no le fue tan bien bueno producto de las
decisiones no sólo de ellos sino de la
gente que lo rodea por eso yo creo que
mira hay tres decisiones tres decisiones
cruciales que afectan la manera en la
que se mueve tu suerte te la voy a
presentar el día de hoy mira la primera
la más fácil
gente de la que te rodeas te ching ron
un conferencista también un escritor
dice que somos el promedio de las cinco
personas de las que nos rodeamos y mucha
gente está diciendo ya valió madre
caamaño madre
el juan holgazán
la carne como receta de quesadilla fácil
o touch
no puede ser andamos promediando bien
bajo bien bajo de esas cinco pero yo
creo que hay tres particulares tres
particulares que tienes que tener
cuidado estos últimos años se ha puesto
muy de moda aquí en méxico donde estamos
haciendo este télex muy de moda el
concepto de aquellos que se roban los
hidrocarburos como se llaman alguien se
acuerda los guays y coleros bueno así
como esos también hay washi coleros de
tu suerte huachi coleros de tu energía
positiva hay andas tú tú te levantaste
como prueba de embarazo positiva
pero te topas a gente de repente que
dices gente mira tres tipos los peores
chico lejos de tu energía la gente que
vive amargada tutelas atrás has visto
gente que llega si dices mamacita quien
te hizo tanto daño para que amanecía es
así
gente que es eterna víctima levante la
mano mira ya en casa donde me están
viendo en este télex piensa quién es
psicólogo o psicóloga de sus amigas te
ha tocado que llegan a contarte puras
puras tragedias
las ves en la mañana y comadre amigo
amiga como mereciste comadre pues aquí
lavando ajeno con jabón prestado
pateando un bote en el monte baldío de
mi vida pero bien pero bien unas
tragedias por eso mira llega hasta los
psicoterapeutas los psicólogos los
psicoanalistas hasta ellos necesitan
terapia y tú ahí andas cargando con los
problemas de todo el mundo como el
pípila y con tu los hay andas tienen
problema do vienen problema de aguas
cuidado con la gente con la que decides
asociarte porque sus decisiones afectan
tu suerte cuidado con la pareja que
escogiste porque sus decisiones afectan
tu suerte por eso si estás viendo este
vídeo y al lado está tu pareja si al
lado estás con amigos voltearlo saber en
este momento verlos fijamente y diles
valorarme
valorarme porque te me voy que aun asi
asi te me voy aguas con los amigos que
escogiste aguas segunda decisión
como jugaste las cartas que te tocaron y
esa es una decisión aún más difícil
fíjate yo tengo la filosofía de que nada
te enseña más que la adversidad la
adversidad es una bendita maestra cuando
tenía 12 años yo conocí la adversidad
por primera vez en 12 años yo era el
niño más feo de la escuela feo con efe
de foco fundido yo sé que ahorita estás
preguntando tú el muñeco el más feo el
más feo y llegaba yo a mi casa llorando
con mi mamá y mi mamá de acuerdo
perfectamente con el corazón roto de no
poder proteger a su hijito en el único
lugar donde no lo puede proteger ahí en
la escuela
ahí es donde más me maltrataban y en ese
momento aprendí fíjate de ser el niño
más feo algo nació en mí que años
después sentado con un reconocido
psicólogo me decía jorge es que para que
el día de hoy tengas secciones en
televisión tengas un programa de radio
tan exitoso tengas secciones de radio en
eeuu 80 ciudad
para que las conferencias en eeuu en
méxico en centroamérica algo que debió
de haber pasado algo que debió de haber
pasado de chiquito y en ese momento me
di cuenta que todo esto que tengo el día
de hoy todo lo que soy es producto de mi
mecanismo de defensa un mecanismo de
defensa a las principales empresas
logran sus más grandes innovaciones de
defenderse en sus más grandes crisis el
día de hoy
pienso en todos aquellos chavos en todos
aquellos chavos que me maltrataba en que
me pegaban que me decían y me pregunto
dónde estarán porque yo estoy dando un
ate de excel esta tarde
dónde estarán quién sabe quién sabe
la adversidad es una bendita maestra si
el día de hoy estás batallando con algo
en tu vida mira agradece agradece porque
no sabes para que está siendo preparado
yo tengo esa filosofía tengo los filos
equals ea tu fe la fe de la gente que me
está viendo el día de hoy pero mira yo
siento que que dios no quiere a los más
preparados para sus planes perfectos yo
siento que dios prepara a los elegidos y
por más que hayas dicho es que me ha
tocado una vida salada jorge no tienes
una idea me ha tocado una vida una vida
terrible para algo está siendo preparado
entre más terrible haya sido tu suerte
más grande es tu proyecto porque no
puede haber héroes si no hay villanos no
puede haber suerte si no hay mala suerte
tercera decisión y última cuanto creíste
y si vieras lo importante que es que
alguien crea creer en ti lo primero
lo primero creer en los demás lo primero
hay una teoría que fue reducida por dos
psicólogos jake epson y rosental donde
los investigadores se llama el efecto el
efecto pigmalión el efecto pigmalión
surge de un estudio que se le hizo a 100
niños de esos 100 niños se les hizo un
examen de capacidades intelectuales se
sacaron los resultados y fueron con los
maestros de los niños les dijeron niños
maestros ahí tienen ustedes a los
alumnos de estos alumnos en secreto les
puedo decir que la mitad de este grupo
es privilegiado mental la otra mitad
pues no tanto me dio promedios promedios
y promedios los maestros a cara y vieron
los resultados no se lo enseñaron a los
niños y empezó el año escolar cuando
transcurre el año escolar al final se
hace el mismo examen el examen para ver
las capacidades intelectuales y resulta
que aquellos niños a los que se le había
sembrado la idea los maestros
eran más inteligentes de que eran
sobresalientes resultaron ser
sobresalientes hay una leyenda incluso
que esté basados en esta misma teoría se
fueron un pueblo en españa y en el
pueblo dijeron hay una sucursal bancaria
y tenemos el reto de que quiere vamos a
hacer que quiebre vamos a hacer este
experimento oye pues empieza alguien a
decir ya sabe siempre hay una red vender
un argüendero chismoso chismosa conoces
gente así en chismosa de esos que
esperar el grupo de whatsapp y nada más
mandar el último chisme de esos que se
la viven mandando monos encuerados te ha
tocado en sus aplicaciones hay andan y
bueno tenías ya sabes empieza a correr
el chisme el banco del pueblo está
quebrado
con el pueblo está quebrado es una
institución financiera el banco del
pueblo está quebrado al principio nadie
creía nadie creía pero después de una
semana uno de los clientes del banco
dijo mira por si las moscas entre que
son peras o son manzanas yo saco mi
dinero de ahí segunda semana el banco
está quebrado nadie creía nadie creía
segunda semana mira lo que era uno se
hicieron diez por si acaso piensas a mi
nombre y tengo mis ahorros de toda la
vida los mil pesitos que guardado sacan
dinero de las del banco lo que eran diez
se hicieron 100 y lo que eran 100 se
hicieron mil y al final del experimento
el banco por esa psicosis que se generó
quebró profecías autocumplidas cuántas
veces nos metemos el pie antes de
iniciar algo porque nos decimos a
nosotros mismos no se pueden de comadre
o esas cosas no te pasan a ti tú eres
como mariana del barrio como madre
siempre fregada siempre fregada
cuántas veces renuncias al proyecto
antes de siquiera iniciarlo hay una
frase que me encanta a mí y se trata a
un hombre o una mujer por lo que es y
seguirá siendo lo que es pero trata lo
por lo que puede llegar a ser y llegará
al máximo de su potencial así como somos
buenos corriendo rumores y los rumores
negativos corren miren un segundo los
rumores de quién se metió con quién de
quién es bien pero sale todo rápido así
como somos buenos para eso empezamos a
correr empecemos a correr el rumor de
que las cosas se pueden cuando empiezas
a correr el rumor de que las cosas se
pueden mirar al principio nadie querrá
nadie nadie lo va a creer nadie querrá
creer pero habrá uno un menso un menso
que se la creyó uno luego habrá diez
luego habrá siete y te garantizo que
cuando lleguen cien
y lo más importante disfruta el trayecto
oye que te ha ido mal en la vida que
estás golpeado golpeada que vives de
tragedias y tú conoces un don doña
tragedias mira ese es un ciclo que no
termina lo que guarda es lo que siempre
es es lo que produce es mira tú como
aeromoza de aerolínea de bajo costo en
turbulencia de pie siempre ante la
adversidad pase lo que pase
la suerte no es suficiente necesitas ese
último componente creer
cree que la tuvo y se la creerá el mundo
yo soy jorge lozano h muchísimas gracias
que dios los bendiga hasta la próxima
[Música]